[Music]
Priyanka Chopra spends the 4th of July
with the Joe Broz the 35 year old
actress was seen riding bikes with Nick
over the holiday along with the 25 year
old singers brother Joe and his fiancee
sophie Turner he's a good accessory the
foursome was rocking patriotic looks for
the outing Sophie in an American flag
visor while Priyanka wore a white tee
blue denim shorts and a red lip I don't
settle for less than that
the pair who took their romance public
in June rarely left each other's side
and were seen holding hands and sharing
some adorable PDA you'll know when I'm
dating someone
later that night Priyanka joined Nick's
entire family including brother Kevin
his wife Danielle and their two little
girls for fun and fireworks on a private
rooftop in NYC Joe and Nick kept with
tradition as the two made sure to snap
their annual fourth photo together this
time with Kevin and their younger
brother Frankie the brotherly tradition
dates all the way back to 2012 Nick
captioned the pic the tradition
continues
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]